what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of animators react
that's right the rarest of the react
shows what I was not expecting the
bloody end what we have the pro here
Alex snow on the couch with us and
you've got a whole list of inspiring
things to talk about here like you're
saying this is CG how are they achieving
that stylistic look in CG the acting is
very motion captury feeling but there's
no emotion
capture w get someone with the Mas on
yeah this is a good example of like the
bare
minimum and you start to see this
awesome pose like how he's pushing with
the elbow and the shoulder all of your
favorite shows right here right now
let's get into
[Music]
it amazing insane all right tell me more
Ninja Turtles Ninja Turtles the new
Ninja Turtles look so exciting cuz the
teenagers sound like teenagers and they
sound like teenagers oddly from like
like the '90s and right now and I don't
know how they're doing that but it's
awesome murder
the what are you doing I mean I think
people's initial response because
they're not used to CG having like such
a unique style and I think people's
initial response is just to go it looks
like spiderverse because that's the only
other thing they can think of that looks
different yeah it definitely has a
looser feel I think that in an
intentional way I don't think that's
worse or better I think it feels more
like a teenager drawing in his note book
it feels fun it feels loose the posing
of the characters they go off model
sometimes and that's
okay like you're saying this is CG how
are they achieving that stylistic look
in CG this is doing a lot of the things
spiderverse and other things are doing
as well like you can even see every time
there's a light source it's kind of like
flickering back and forth it almost
looks like they've gone in and actually
drawn just like some scribbles over the
light yeah and but obviously the light
is hitting the character character is in
a very correct way there might be three
versions of the lighting texture on the
character but it's built in and then on
top of that they're having realistic
lighting and then on top of it they have
draw overs you see in the smoke like
that's 2D animated and I think sometimes
the animator is doing that sometimes an
effects artist is doing that it almost
looks like some of these shots where
it's like the handdrawn scribbles are
actually tracked into the 3D scene like
you're actually seeing a little bit of
perspective shift on those Tail Lights
100 where like the scribble is actually
it's got a little bit of Parallax even
though it's single scribble that's not
exactly animating frame to frame it's
animating every few frames yeah so
that's a good call so there's a couple
ways you can do that you can do that in
comp you can also have it on a card and
attach it and parent it and animate it
in the scene there's a lot of different
solutions to the same problem but it's
definitely handdrawn and you can see
that with the scribbles and the
variation I'm sure they had like at
least some assets that they could plug
in you know things like the sword moving
here drawing those lines that's quick
for someone just to do on top and the
animator might even do that on their
play blast before it's rendered just to
make sure it's working because doing
lines like smear frames or multiples
will slow down or speed up your
animation spiderverse uses chromatic
abrasion and smears and lines and this
and I think Turtles is taking the same
approach of what's best for the moment
what's best for the scene how much of
this is appropriate and what does it
make it feel like and I think feel over
everything else is the most important
visual effects allow us to achieve the
impossible daring action sequences
creatures you've never seen before
worlds that could never exist but one
thing it can't do is give you a good
night of sleep that's something I've
always struggled with but luckily
today's SPS are Helix sleep has provided
us with a new mattress that might solve
all my problems Helix sleep offers
premium mattresses customized to fit
your needs and they're conveniently
shipped right to your door free shipping
and in the US everybody sleeps
differently and Helix knows that so they
made a sleep quiz that matches your
unique body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you so both
my girlfriend and I are s sleepers and
we both enjoy you know not too firm not
too soft right that goldilock zone based
on our results we were matched with the
Helix midnight Lux mattress I run pretty
warm at night so we decided to upgrade
to the glacio teex cooling cover which
is a great way to keep cool during those
La summer months and you get a 100 night
sleep trial to test the mattress out to
ensure that you love it Helix mattresses
include a 10-year warranty and they
offer financing options and flexible
payment plans and this year Helix
launched their newest and most high-end
collection yet the Helix Elite mattress
the Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models to combine
high-end luxury with personalized
Comfort tailored to your
preferences I can feel the the heat
being sapped out of my body and I'm
being lulled to sleep but before I do
you guys can head to helixsleep.com
crew for 20% off your first order of a
helix mattress and you also get these
two free pillows also keep an eye on the
Helix website this month because they
have some holiday sales popping up
throughout November so this is a great
time to upgrade your sleep okay you guys
I go back and watch
react
okay so this is a scene from Encanto I
brought it the animator was Dave Harden
who is absolutely incredible if you ask
him he'll say the opposite uh super
humble this scene specifically to me
stood out watching the movie as just a
really well done moment even though it's
a very like subtle and heartfelt moment
he's pushing shapes and timing as she
gets you know a little goofier as she's
trying to cheer him up so you talk about
the animation here kind of evolv Ving
over the course of the shot what are
some of the specific animations that
you're seeing here for her character
that stand out yeah I just love like the
choices being made also they're under a
bed and like super contained and there's
only so much movement and things you can
do but I think that also enhances the
performance of like her hands are
opening closing but pretty much her
General pose only changes once or twice
and then you see her face kind of die
down go really internal and think it's
all subtle yeah it's really small you
can see the corners start to rise up a
little bit as she's like trying to kind
of take herself out of it I always see
like limitations given on animation
because of convenience or time or effort
or the annoyance of constraints and
things like that and when you're not
afraid to touch a character or to you
know adjust your hair or whatever it is
it feels more real because people don't
just sit and they're like in one pose
and be like I can't cost money by moving
my shirt uh you know and that's a real
thing so I just think her performance is
so real and it's just really through the
eyes and the drop of the corners of the
mouth and stuff and it's just super
cool uh okay so this is in kto Min recap
there's lots of these there's lots of
these Recaps by this dude and uh they're
all amazing he works with Studios and
different Studios to help him accomplish
it but it's all driven from his kind of
style and uh Vision he does them for
Disney movies Pixar movies live action
movies everything
oh
aa
it's not bad animation at all it's
actually absolutely fantastic but I just
mean it's different we just watched one
of the most detailed specific nuanced
animations in even the whole of Encanto
and this is not that but this is telling
the story and all the ideas and all of
these things are so specific and so
clear you know he's not doing that much
he's committing to all the ideas and
that's the important thing what I was
not expecting the bloody any what yeah
the the chainsaw man ending
[Applause]
hey his skill set of course is animation
in the eye for like what's needed he's
leaning 100% into the comedy cuz it's
comedy whatever what
whatever genius did not expect that I
feel like it's it's about communicating
the jokes right yeah it's a little bit
like Rand and Stimpy like of course it
looks nothing like R simpy but it has
like a hyper detailed hands when it
needs it if it helps the joke it leans
into it and otherwise it just is what it
needs to be you take for granted the
idea that you can just draw the
character and he has a very specific
style and it fits everything and to do
that and to come up with that and to be
consistent with that is really hard and
uh he does an awesome job at that if we
want to see some worse animation in
Disney movies let's check out some of my
stuff so this is from Strange World
Jagger even though he's much bigger than
you would think like he's going to Lug
himself around he's athletic he's lived
here for years and years and years
Searcher and the rest of the gang are
new to the area I wanted Searcher to
feel like he was at the very least like
more concerned he's constantly breaking
his eyeline with the other character to
check his hands and his feet as he
climbs going back to so that was like an
important choice for me to to kind of
sell that nervousness and he's looking
at his feet like is that in and you can
see his knees like wobble it's not
just like want things to feel loose no
just the pointless Explorer stuff I
filmed a bunch of reference which we can
watch but like I climbed on a playground
and again you get something to get the
general like body mechanics and so
that's me being Jagger and these will be
too long but I just like broke into a a
apartment complex nearby I was like that
fence is perfect and this is me ignoring
my kids at the playground to film
reference uh and so it was really just
to get that feeling of like the weight
of it which I knew I could figure out
but I wanted some sort of a
bass and so this was me trying to feel
like the grip and the uncomfortability
Searcher is more flexible than me but
also he shouldn't feel like this is a
normal thing so I'm surprised at how
detailed your performance actually is it
doesn't feel like you're just like kind
of making it up it feels like everything
you're doing is actually very
intentional and planned totally so
sometimes I'll thumbnail place your foot
forwards more and yeah so so for this
shot the way I started it was I didn't
have his leg going up um that was
actually an awesome note from uh Michael
Franchesco who was my lead on the
sequence and again it just pushed that
original idea of like I'm comfortable
I'm stable I'm trying to catch up I'm
uncomfortable even further and then it
also connected them he was always
grabbing him but this way it felt like
he was saving him a little bit too but
nonchalantly so you're like does he care
about him does he not care about him and
it left a little bit more uh
unknown this looks like it's from from
love death and robots is this like the
same Studio yeah so this is uh also a
film from Alberto mialo I might be
saying that completely wrong I'm sorry
this is one that a lot of people haven't
seen even though I won the Oscar I think
he is more of an artist that likes to be
in a cave and do things his way and it's
like I have a very specific vision and
he is a very unique and specialized and
extreme Talent someone who knows what
they want and just kind of needs that to
flow out of them
it feels like something coming from
liveaction a really heavy liveaction
shoot or a base and a very planned out
it feels like this could be a filtered
video yeah but what's weird
theyit oh that Sim satisfying what's
interesting about his style is the
acting is very motion captury feeling
but there's no emotion capture right
which is kind of how it felt in the
other ones we've looked at before too
it's the sty he likes to go for it would
absolutely work in a full feature film
of course back when we back when we did
our first animators react episode we
brought up this concept of appeal yeah
and I understood everything I was like
appeal as in like just make people like
your cartoon it's like yeah draw a
picture of a character that people want
to look at and like in a way it's like
it seems so basic but at the same time
in a way like unattainably
specific it's like oh yeah just make
good art yeah it's exactly that and I'm
using it like that in in the laziest way
possible but like it is it's like now of
course you're going to weigh your what's
important to you as a filmmaker is
composition the most important like it's
very prominent here maybe maybe the
importance of the character's appeal and
where their face angle is isn't as
important as capturing the Silhouettes
on a very specific background in a very
specific moment a well-run pipeline to
me is a director with a vision but
flexible we're empowering our creators
to create their specific vision and if
this is your type of thing we do it the
best and if you like this we have one of
those too and we're not getting in the
way of the people we we trust and we
[Music]
hire Primal if you haven't seen it is an
awesome show you can watch it on Max I
would just want to bring up these These
are from gendi tachovsky he did powerp
girls samr Jack a bunch of
stuff he has a vision in his head and he
has the artistic chops to kind of bring
it to life through design story boards
himself the top is his story boards of
this clip the bottom is the final
picture he didn't animate it himself
Studio lash who did chyros and they did
uh Star Wars Visions the dancer one in
the latest season similarities between
the boards and the final product are it
seems one to one I mean it just seems
like the team is plusy what he gave
them this is another great scene it's
just very quick there's gendy original
Boards of him slicing there's kind of
like a first pass and you start to see
this awesome pose like how he's pushing
with the elbow and the shoulder to drive
all the kind of like what we talked with
try gun like how that POS was kind of
stiff everything drives and if you see
his initial boards they don't have any
of that it's just he comes and he hits
and so if you were to tell AI or a
computer to in between this I think not
now but in the future if you drew enough
key frames and it studied turnarounds
and even if you did a first season of
the show and it it learned from that and
it learned the main characters you could
potentially cut down on the amount of
cleanup and and and color you're going
to need and it would be more about
fixing with like a really good
supervisor team that you can spend money
on but what you won't get is these
choices of leading with the shoulder and
the elbow and creating this like very
graphic triangle pointing upwards before
it drives to the camera and and and
pushing that far arm back and G's
telling you what he needs and it's great
and that gives the animators everything
they need to know what the point of the
shot is and then they go what if I eased
out of this pose what if I stayed on the
bottom a little longer so it had that
much more power when I pop up and this
idea of making specific artistic choices
as your additive and and what humans can
do to me it will help you with the stuff
that was in of course and allow you to
spend more time polishing the only me
and and true collaboration I think
whether it's with a tool or a team or a
person is this game of telephone and
this goal of the initial idea not being
completely lost and utter crap being
spewed the other side and instead
maintaining that idea and adding to it
and ending up with something really cool
and special at the end and I think this
is a clear depiction of how gendy an
already extremely talented director with
a vision an artist and animator gives
the freedom and chose an amazing studio
like Studio a to take what he had and
make it that much more incredible and
arguably definitely one of my favorite
series ever
made this is everyone's favorite
airplane animation JJ the Jet Plane
J so i' I've been seeing JJ around
lately and so I thought it was a good
example of excellent animation but is it
like intentionally goofy
no watch me here I
go I feel like they're animating it by
like real time yeah like like a Hot
Wheels yeah like they have the mouse and
like they click and drag for like the
head to change and they just record the
motion it has that love that style of
Animation I would say that's the case
but it seems not smooth enough to be
this is a good example of like the bare
minimum this is really creeping me out
what are we watching like what is this
is this for kids is this a kid show is
this an actual show or is this just a
like this
that's someone with the mouse going yeah
it's got to be it's got to be live mouse
capture yeah it's that or a puppet I've
seen that inconsistent motion you get
from using a mouse it's a style in and
of itself and I I feel like that's
exactly what I'm looking at this look
I've lost my pointer enough times on the
screen and wiggle my mouse until I see
it to know that this is somebody
wiggling their Mouse yeah yeah I mean
it's just weird this is the first time
I've seeing any eyebrow movement this is
a good example of appeal right yeah f
yeah I mean this is like leaning too
hard into your tool and I think as soon
as you start taking out the creativity
or the director's Vision or the artist's
hand you end up with more stuff like
this and an abundance I mean I
desperately need a show of of you two
and Sam as these characters but uh I'm
very curious to see more like children's
show animations and how janky they could
be so if you got some examples I know
some of you are parents out there you've
passively seen some of your kids
watching this stuff got any examples
leave a comment down below
we'll check it out soon if people wanted
to follow more of your work where would
be a good spot they could go always
Instagram is a good place to go even
though I haven't been updating so much
double plus Productions we should have
more and more stuff coming up we have a
lot of exciting things we've already
finished that just haven't been released
yet so we're excited to share those and
I'll probably come back and show some of
that stuff off we've got a very cool
episode coming out tomorrow on the
corridor crew channel are you subscribed
you might miss it if you're not I'm just
saying thanks for watching see you next
week